hey guys it's monday January 25th and
it's also Australia Day which is
probably why our Australian team is out
somewhere drinking for X or Cooper's
green or to ease or some other delicious
Australian beer so that just leaves you
me in gamespot news first up fallout 4
mods are coming to console but when soon
asked by a fan when mods will be
available on console the official
fallout twitter account replied we'll be
sharing more details soon stay tuned
though there's been loads of mods for
fallout 4 made on PC including my
personal favorite the hot mama Murphy
mod the game's official modding tool
suite the Creation Kit is not yet
available this is due to arrive early
this year on PC with some supported mods
coming first xbox one and eventually to
ps4 in an interview late last year
Bethesda marketing executive Pete Hines
talked at a high level about the
company's ideas for how it hopes the pc
console modding system will function we
wanted to be a really streamlined fun
experience there's still specifics that
we have to work out it's part of a post
launch plan so no exact date yet but
confirmed soon in sad delay news mighty
number 9 has been delayed a third time
keiji inafune a spiritual successor to
megaman mighty number 9 has been delayed
again that announcement was made in an
update to Kickstarter backers in
preparation for february's release of
mighty number 9 we've been working hard
with our partners to resolve any network
issues and porting work necessary to
publish mighty number 9 on various
platforms however the issues relating to
network modes were more critical than
expected it's become apparent that we
need to delay the game from its februari
knife release date according to ena
Funes the delay is necessary as a
solution of the issues are slightly
different for each of the platforms the
games being released on since there are
no longer updates being made for the
game's engine each
must be manually implemented a new
release date for mighty number nine not
been specified but it's likely soon
realistically however the game is likely
to launch in spring 2016 finally scott
cawthon the creator of the five nights
at freddy's series notorious for
cranking out games faster than the
toupee in a hurricane faster than a dog
on roller skates faster than a drunk on
a moped faster than Kirby's digestive
tract faster than a turd on Tuesday
faster than sonic on a speed date well
this one came out a little too fast and
it has some problems but as it turns out
his apologies are also fast following
his recent admission that the game was
released too early five nights at
freddies world developer scott cawthon
has pulled his latest release from steam
he said even though the game had a very
positive rating with eighty-seven
percent I wasn't satisfied with the
reviews and ratings it was getting for
that reason I've decided to remove the
game from steam it's naturally begs the
question of what's gonna happen everyone
who paid ten bucks coffin said that he's
requested that valve offer refunds
regardless of how long it's been owned
or played allowing anyone to get their
money back who wants it typically you
can't request a steam refund after
playing a game for more than two hours
Cawthon stated when I'm ready to update
the game I will replace the demo
currently on gamejolt with the full game
from this point forward the game will
always be free even though we released
the game too early it's got a lot of
features to fix and it's kind of dumb
it's hard to be mad at the guy but he's
already offering refunds and promising
that the game will be free soon so
that's all the news for today and Jess
will be back again tomorrow have a good
one I'll see you guys later
you